NYLANDER AS CHRIS KREIDER PUTS
THERE'S GOODROW OUT OF THE BOX.
OUT O ASIDE BY
CAMPBELL.
REVERSED BY MUZZIN.
ANDD
>> Chris: NOW PANARIN CENTRES IT
AND THAT ONE OFF THE POS
RANGERS STARTING OUT.
PASS UP THE BOARDS. CAMPBELL
AND ENDED UP CREATING A
TURNOVER.
ZIBANEJAD COMING IN FR LOOSE TO
RANGERS.
AND THEY WILL SEND IT:  YOUR MO
RATE IS LOW FROM THE  TO DUMP IT
SPEZZA, TO MATTHEWS.
AND THAT DEFLECTS OUT OF PLAY.
IT IS ZIBANEJAD.
AND HE BOGGLED THE PASS.
COMING ACROSS.
TONIGHT.
>> Chris: 99 CAREER MULTIPOINT T
FIVE-Y OFF BUNTING TO THE SIDE.
AND THE DEFENCEMAN IN FRONT. WO.
AUSTON MATTHEWS OUT AT CENTRE
ON TOO EARLY.SANDIN.
DERMOTT FIRES THAT AND IT IS
BLOCKED EN ROUTE.
WEARING NUMBER 14.
BRENDAN SHANAHAN's F TO BUILD O
SEASON LONG STANLEY CUP HABITS.
STREAM THE
MATTHEWS.
CUT OFF BY FOX.
AND PLAYED OUT TO CENTRE. PENAL
NEW YORK.
DERMOTT IN  LEGENDARY GOALTENDER
BACK.
>> Craig: TWO GREAT PLAYS
GETTING BACK A
FRONT OF THE NET.
FOXTHERE.
AND GOT IT TO BRODIE. WITH
MARNER.
BUNTING HEADING TO THE BENCH AN
BETWEEN THESE TEAMS REREAY TO
THE NET.
AND JUST SHOT IT WIDE! BROKEN U.
AND MATTHEWS COULDN'T GET LOOSE.
SLOWED UP.
BUT IT IS T.J. BRODIE RACING
AFTER IT. A GAME NOT A LOT WAS
AWAY.
HOW ABOUT THOSE SAVES COMINANOT.
SHESTERKIN GETS BA
ALONE.
WHAT A READ BY CAMPBELL KNOWING
THAT'S NOT COMING ACROSS THE
SEAM.
INSTEAD A QUICK SHOT THAT HE